Thanks to Babbel, a language learning
app, for sponsoring this episode.
If you’re interested in growing your language
skills, Microcosmos viewers get up to 65%
off when you sign up using
our link in the description.
This algae is stressed.
And we can tell it’s stressed
because it’s doing something that you
might also do when you find yourself
in a difficult situation. It’s turning red.
But while blushing brightly for everyone to see
might make your situation worse, this
algae can do something else that sounds,
honestly, very appealing: it can curl up in
a ball and just wait out the worst of it.
This algae is called Haematococcus, and
it is not, physiologically speaking,
turning red through the same mechanisms that
you and I do when we are stressed and blushing.
We flush with blood. Meanwhile, the Haematococcus
does not have blood. But depending on the state of
your ancient Greek, you might recognize its
name translates loosely to “blood berries,”
a name that seems fitting for a
round, reddish organism like this one.
But as poetically sanguinary as the name is,
Haematococcus flushes with something else
altogether, a chemical we can see traveling
through the algae and up the food chain,
until it winds up on our own plates.
But before we get to the dinner table,
let us talk about where we got our Haematococcus:
from a centuries old cemetery in Warsaw, Poland,
filled with beautiful sculptures and birdbaths.
For James, our master of microscopes, it is
important to respect the tombs there. So, don’t
worry, these microbes don’t have particularly
spooky origins. He’s there for the birdbaths,
where the algae lines the surfaces like rust.
The Haematococcus likely arrived at the
birdbath thanks to the birds themselves,
and there it would have remained until maybe
another bird came along, except this time,
your favorite microbe hunter came first.
In addition to birdbaths, Haematococcus are
often found in transient pools of freshwater,
like puddles after a rainfall. And as you can
see on your screen, not all Haematococcus are
red. Plenty of them are green, which makes sense
because Haematococcus is a member of the phylum
Chlorophyta and that phylum is full of many
other unicellular green algae like the volvox.
And as algae, Haematococcus are green,
photosynthetic, and very easy to eat, which makes
them a simple solid foundation for an ecosystem.
But even seemingly simple creatures
have requests of the world around them,
whether that’s for certain levels of light, or a
particular temperature. And if you were to say,
go to a hotel and your room was 100 degrees,
you got a few solid options to fix that problem.
You could find the thermostat. And if that
doesn’t work, you could complain to the manager
or even just go find another place to stay.
But those are not great options for the
Haematococcus. There’s no thermostat to
change, there’s no manager and if the
temperature gets too high, there’s only so
much a single-celled body can do to survive.
So instead, the Haematococcus does what I’m
sure many of us wish we could do when we were
in an uncomfortable situation: it takes
a little bit of a break, forming a cyst
that allows it to rest and survive
until conditions are good again.
When you’re looking at this mixture of
Haematococcus, you’re looking at a gathering
of algae in different phases of their lives.
The most active ones are called macrozooids,
or zoospores. They might be shaped like spheres,
ellipsoids, or even pears. And they’re encased
in a thick gelatinous wall, with two flagella
extending out in front to zip the algae around.
But most importantly, here at
this stage, the algae is green.
The Haematococcus rarely reproduces sexually,
and when it’s a macrozooid, it divides rapidly,
forming around 2 to 32 copies of itself. But
it makes sense to move around and make more of
yourself when conditions are good. What happens
though when you’re in a comfortable pool of water
one day, and in much more dire straits the next?
Well, for the Haematococcus, this is the point at
which it all begins to change. The algae
sheds its flagella, layers up its wall,
and shifts into a ball. This is the
Haematococcus as a palmella, a resting cell.
But if stress has taught me anything,
it is that things can always get worse.
And for this little cell, it can get hotter or
saltier or just too bright. And when that happens,
the palmella morphs into an aplanospore.
Its walls become even heavier duty,
shielding it from the outside. But most striking,
this is when the haematococcus becomes red.
The red is practical, the product
of a chemical called astaxanthin.
Astaxanthin is a carotenoid, a type of reddish
yellow pigment found in plants and microbes. But
it’s more than just a pretty color. Astaxanthin
is an extremely powerful antioxidant, protecting
the cyst from potential damage as it rests.
You’ve probably seen astaxanthin in real life,
except you might not have
called it that. You might
have just called it “pink,” or “salmon pink.”
Astaxanthin is found in plants, fungi, bacteria,
and yes, in algae. And haematococcus, is
considered to be one of the best natural producers
of astaxanthin, able to produce up to 5% of its
dry weight in astaxanthin. For comparison, another
astaxanthin-producing algae called Chlorella makes
around 0.001% of its dry weight in astaxanthin
Now the reason we find astaxanthin
in so many animals is because,
algae make for good food, whether you
are a shrimp, salmon, or flamingo.
It’s striking that the color we call “salmon
pink” is a sign of both the salmon’s contentment
and the algae’s demise. Perhaps we should start
calling it “haematococcus pink” instead, an
acknowledgement of the work of the haematococcus,
which endures so long after its death.
It would be a fitting tribute after all to a
color you might have eaten a few times yourself.
The salmon, sure, which might have fed on
synthetic astaxanthin or algae. But even
the chicken eggs you buy might have gotten their
yolk color boosted by algae added to chicken feed.
Astaxanthin has its uses outside of our food,
whether in our cosmetics or nutraceuticals.
And while much of that is synthetic, a copy we’ve
learned to make by studying the chemistry of
astaxanthin, there’s also a push in the market for
“natural” products, a push that has led to renewed
interest in the haematococcus algae and its
wondrous ability to produce its own astaxanthin.
But for the haematococcus that’s just something
weird going on in the outside world, a factor
far beyond its control and its interest. Whatever
comes its way--whether it's a scientist, a bird,
or a fish--all the haematococcus is concerned with
is its own survival. What belongs to the algae
will one day belong to another organism, passed
on through chemistry and made into something new
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you again to Babbel for sponsoring
this episode of Journey to the Microcosmos.
Babbel is a language learning app that helps
you use a new language in real-life situations
after only five hours of practice. And it
offers lessons in 14 different languages.
Whether you want to travel somewhere new and be
able to speak the language when you get there,
or you’re just looking for some self-improvement
that you can do from the comfort of your couch,
Babbel courses are professionally designed
by language experts who take into account
your native language and it will teach you
vocabulary and grammar skills that you can
use in real life situations -- like asking
for directions or ordering at a restaurant.
And Babbel even has a podcast, short
stories, games and new live virtual
classes from certified teachers so you can
learn in whatever format works for you.
As a Microcosmos viewer, you’ll get
up to 65% off if you download Babble
and sign up by clicking the
link in the description.
All the folks on the screen right now, they
are our Patreon patrons. And if you are one
of those people, the Microcosmos team is very
grateful and we just want to say “Thanks.” If
you would like to become a Microcosmos patron,
you can go to Patreon.com/journeytomicro
where you can also find some really good
stuff that we’ve got only for our patrons.
If you want to see more from our
Master of Microscopes James Weiss,
you can check out Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there’s
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.